It's time to introduce a new regular expression--plus.
This is really handy when we want to match one or more of something.
This is a very concise way of listing, actually, an infinite number of possibilities.
If I write the regular expression "a" followed by a plus, it matches "a," "aa," "aaa," "aaaa."
The plus looks back to the previous regular expression and changes the meaning.
Instead of just matching that once, you match it once or more--as many times as you'd like.
Here I've shown another example. We're looking for 0 through 1 repeated one or more times.
The interpretation here is every time you repeat you can make a different choice.
This matches "0" and "1," "00" and "11," but also "01."
This required us to pick a 0 the first time and a 1 the second time.
That's totally fine with the plus.
"1010" is a favorite year of mine.
It's about when Murasaksi Shikibu wrote The Tale of Genji.
She is often credited with writing the first novel--the first psychological novel,
although this is the subject of some dispute.
There is a minor bit of ambiguity I need to clear up with this plus.
Let's say that we're looking for numbers 0 through 9 plus in the string "13 from 1 in 1776."
One possible answer is 13, 1, and 1776,
but this plus just means 1 or more.
Is there anything that says that I have to match them all at the same time
or could I break up 1776 into four different one-letter strings.
It turns out that there is a rule in regular expressions called "maximal munch,"
which says that a regular expression should consume, or eat, or match
the biggest string it can and not smaller parts.
So we and Python and other people studying regular expressions are going to get this answer:
13, 1, 1776, because 1776 is the maximal munch we can get here for 0 through 9 plus.
Don't stop early. Go all the way.
All right. Let's get a little more practice with compound regular expression matching,
including the plus.
Down here I've written a regular expression dot findall expression in Python
and a bunch of possible answers.
I'd like you to check the ones that could be elements of the return value of this Python expression.
We're looking for 0 through 9 followed by--oh, what does this mean?
I haven't shown this to you yet.
We just have open brackets, a space, and a closed bracket.
That means just match space.
Then finally 0 through 9 plus.
Remember the plus only applies to this last 0 through 9.
We're looking for all of these in that torture string I made up earlier.
Let's try it out.